du vieux port de Marseille bondé aux
rues pavé de Rennes ou encore à Toulouse
[Musique]
757000 manifestants dans toute la France
selon les autorités c'est donc moi que
les 19 et 31 janvier ils étaient un
million
272000 manifestants la semaine dernière
puisque vous voulez la vérité la vérité
les chiffres officiels c'est 9
universités bloquées 14 lycées bloqués
on est loin des 200 14
si vous voulez on va ensuite se refaire
un débat vous me réinviter je vous donne
la liste et les photographies des
universités qui ont été bloquées
mais en tout cas vous l'avez dit encore
beaucoup de monde l'objectif aujourd'hui
c'est de maintenir la pression sur le
gouvernement au moment où commence le
débat dans l'hémicycle c'est de
journalistes d'accord
probablement les mêmes que vous sortez
quand vous vous référez au cabinet
occurrence pour donner les chiffres des
manifestations les chiffres je les tiens
des syndicalistes des gens qui sont sur
le terrain des gens qui font des choses
pour pouvoir le faire si vous voulez si
le gouvernement persiste à ne pas
écouter
et bien forcément il faudra monter d'un
cran d'ailleurs il y a des salariés qui
nous le disent déjà
fermement
[Musique]
terrible pour le peuple et je ne peux
pas dire ce que sera la réponse mais en
tout cas ça n'enlèvera rien notre
détermination jusqu'à peu il n'y ait
fait désormais il est poursuivi pour
favoritisme et c'est ce monsieur du soft
que vous chargez de mener contre mener
votre réforme des retraites c'est lui
l'homme qui nous veut du bien en nous
volant deux ans de vie alors là on voit
un type qui est en train d'essayer de
mettre le feu carrément à la poubelle
soit de récupérer ces bouteilles vides
pour pouvoir s'en servir comme
projectile et alors là voilà bravo il y
a un principe la présomption d'innocence
et moi je veux dire toute ma confiance
toute ma confiance du président de la
République à Olivier du socle qui est un
ministre engagé qui a été un député
engagé qui était amer engagé je tiens à
dénoncer un fait extrêmement grave 4 ou
5 de nos députés femmes viennent de
recevoir un message leur indiquant que
Anne leurs enfants est à l'hôpital
hospitalisé il s'agit donc là d'une
manœuvre qui visent à empêcher ou à
distraire les députés du rassemblement
national de leur présence
j'ai eu un monsieur qui m'annonçait que
quelqu'un de ma famille venait de
rentrer à l'hôpital de Calais en urgence
et qu'il fallait que je rappelle cet
hôpital il y avait une certaine réalité
dans le message parce que voilà on vous
nomme on vous dit Perpignan j'étais un
petit peu catastrophique sur le moment
il y a ensuite j'ai vu que deux de mes
collègues avaient reçu des messages du
même type oui c'est la même personne qui
a procédé aux trois appels avec selon
Marine Le Pen un but politique
l'objectif de ces appels malveillants
était de pousser une ou deux députés
signataires ou trois d'ailleurs député
signataires ne pas être présent et s'il
manque un seul signataire la motion
tombe et n'est pas étudiée à l'Assemblée
nationale et alors on peut étudier une
autre motion référendaire par exemple
d'autres notions référendaires
effectivement ont été déposées par
exemple par la gauche et c'est ce que
souligne en sous-tex c'est députés du
rassemblement national c'est gravissime
c'est honteux et c'est indigne et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je pense que
collectivement il ne faut pas laisser
passer ses agissements ça ne vient pas
des rangs de la nup ça ne vient pas je
ne sais pas de qui ça vient en tout cas
je peux vous dire que aucun d'entre nous
n'aurait eu l'idée de chercher à
éloigner les députés du RN par des
moyens aussi odieux que ceux que vous
exprimez depuis hier des milliers de
secouristes et de pompiers Turcs se
démène pour extraire le maximum de
survie
[Musique]
ce sont ainsi près de 8000 femmes hommes
et enfants qui ont pu être sauvés pour
l'instant et maintenant en 2032 c'est
une blague pas du tout ah bon ah non non
ce n'est pas du tout
écouter je prends le pari on prend le
pari bon mais une fois sorti des
décombres le froid la pluie et la neige
les attendent le dénuement est extrême